Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wir haben ein Buch vor uns.
Ja.
Du hast es ausgedruckt, ich hab es auch ausgedruckt. Und ich konnte sogar Verwendung finden, denn mein Fenster weht im Wind immer zu, also hab ich das Buch ins Fenster gelegt, damit es nicht immer zu knallt.
Das ist vermutlich das Sinnvollste, was man damit machen kann. Lesen sollte man es eigentlich nicht, wir haben es aber dennoch gelesen. Es heißt Links, Deutsch, Deutsch, Links, herausgegeben von Pauline Voss und Julian Reichelt, also von Leuten aus dem Nios-Verlag, die haben ein Autoren-Team zusammengestellt aus Henrik M. Broder, Fürsten Gloria von Ton und Taxis, Wolfgang Kubicki, Waldi Hartmann, Birgit Kelle, Norbert Beuls, Harald Maartenstein, Marc Friedrich.
Joachim Steinhöfel.
Ja, um über das zu schreiben, was eigentlich, sagen sie, seit Jahrzehnten in Deutschland schiefläuft, nämlich dieser linke Diskurs, ist so dominant geworden, dass man jetzt ein Wörterbuch rausgeben muss, damit man auch gefeiert ist vor all dieser schrecklichen Sprache, die die Linken hineingebracht haben, denn Sprache ist Macht. Damit beginnt auch gleich das Vorwort von Julian Reichelt, nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache. Und die politisch-mediale Sprache in Deutschland ist Links. Das können wir erstmal in Frage stellen, dass wirklich nichts mächtiger als die Sprache ist, aber wir wissen, die Sprache ist mächtig. Dieses Buch war einige Wochen schon auf Platz 1 der Bestseller-Listen. Nun wissen wir, dafür muss man jetzt nicht irrsinnig viele Bücher verkaufen, aber doch schon einige. Vermutlich, um auf eine Bestseller Platz 1 zu kommen, ja so 7.000, 8.000 wird man da schon die Woche absetzen müssen, damit das geschieht. Aber was wir hier vor allem vor uns haben, und ich finde, deshalb müssen wir über dieses Buch diskutieren, ist sozusagen ein Wahlprogramm oder ein Koalitionsprogramm. Sollte es eine Koalition geben, eine schwarz-blaue, also AfD und CDU, und das wäre ja dann nur ein Teil der CDU, der da mitgehen würde mit dieser Koalition, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich die Programmatik auf der man aufbauen kann.
Denn so viel liest du daraus, Programmatik?
Ja, natürlich auch in all ihrer Dürftigkeit, so müssen wir es natürlich sehen. Aber um das ganz klar zu machen, wir reden hier nicht von einer Höcke, AfD und einer Koalition mit der CDU, das nicht, sondern eine Weide, AfD und eine Weide, AfD, die koalieren würde mit gewissen Teilen der CDU, die sagen wir nicht Wüst oder Günter sind.
Dann nimmst du dieses Buch schon sehr ernst. Ich mache deswegen einen alternativen Einstieg. Denn klar, unter der Maxime, dass die CDU jetzt auch keine Programmatik hat, haben wir es dann mit einer neuen Nicht-Programmatik zu tun. Vor allem kann man so natürlich machen. Was wir hier vor allem vor uns haben, ist ja so ein kalkulierter Joke. Also man macht sie einfach witzig. Und zwar über etwas. Also es ist ja ein politisches Sachbuch, das also auf eine politische Realität, und dann kommt der Reiche gleich mit Gramsci um die Ecke und sagt, ja Worte, Bedeutung, Realität, das ist ja alles nicht handfest, aber ideologisch mächtig und manifest.
Wer die Hegomenie haben will, muss über die Sprache verfügen. Er tut hier so, als müsse man jetzt Gramsci lesen. Die Wahrheit ist natürlich, dass von diesen ganzen Rechten sich niemand mit Gramsci auseinandergesetzt hat, sondern vielleicht so eine Passage kennt und sagt, ja irgendwas mit Hegomenie.
Genau. Und unter Hegomenie-Gesichtspunkten ist ja für mich ein Ansatzpunkt zu sagen, das ist zumindest theoretisch, analytisch wahnsinnig interessant. Denn wir haben es ja mit einem Buch zu tun, bei dem fast alle Worte im Grunde nur von rechts verwendet werden, um die linke Seite zu markieren. Ja. Aber das sind jetzt keine Bekenntnisworte, mit denen die Linken sich zu erkennen gibt. Also wir gehen nachher Worte durch, wo man sich so fragt, also das sind keine Worte, die man hört im Alltag. Sich darüber lustig zu machen, ist also schon allein das Wort zu benutzen, bedeutet, ja gut, du bist halt rechts vom Spektrum und willst den Linken was unterschieben. Da denkt also jemand in diesem Spektrum. Und dann wird es noch inhaltlich aufgeladen, also ein so angebliches Vorzeichen verkehrt, wo ich mir denke, nee, es gibt ja schon das empirische Substrat des Wortgehaltes, nicht wie du es dir ausdenkst. Und jetzt wird es ein bisschen tricky. Wir haben es ja mit einem Wörterbuch zu tun. Wörterbücher stellen dir Erklärungen zu Worten zur Verfügung, bei denen man Fragen hat. Also im Alltag stellt man fest, in dem Text steht Inferenz, was heißt denn das eigentlich? Also schlägt man einem Wörterbuch nach. Und ich habe jetzt gerade argumentiert, diese Wörter begegnen einem im Alltag gar nicht und trotzdem kommen Erklärungen. Wir haben also schon, bevor es inhaltlich relevant wird, es mit einer Formverletzung zu tun, also einer Kalkulation mit dem Format, die ist jetzt müßig zu sagen, nicht aufgeht. Das ist typischerweise so. Aber eine der Erklärungen, warum wir es hier mit so einem Wörterbuch zu tun haben, ist ja auch und ich nehme mal deine Version jetzt, um sie in die Kamera zu zeigen. Man sieht hier in diesem Text, anders als bei Bibi, hier sind nicht nur Absätze, sondern hier beginnen einfach immer richtig Abschnitte. Hier ist so Fett geschrieben. Hier werden Begriffe.
Ja, man arbeitet mit Lammata.
Genau. Das bedeutet, wofür ist dieses Buch gedacht? Das liegt so rum, man schlägt wahllos eine Seite auf und man weiß, seit der 124, das Wort Queer wird vorgestellt. Ich muss also jetzt nicht zurückbleiben zum Thema Qualitätsmedien, weil es gibt keinen Zusammenhang. Und das Format kennen wir von dem sehr erfolgreichen Buch von Hoss und Hopf. Man guckt einfach auf die Uhr, 8. Februar. Na dann gehe ich mal zum 8. Februar, was soll ich denn heute machen? Und dann hat sich das auf einer Seite ergeben. Also wir haben es eigentlich gar nicht mit dem Buch. Also Wörterbuch hier zu sagen ist schon bescheuert. Buch dazu zu sagen ist genauso bescheuert.
Na ja, jetzt will ich nicht Nios verteidigen, aber diese Form finde ich gar nicht so uninteressant. Denn durchaus sind hier ja Begriffe drin, die man aus dem linken Diskurs kennt. Aber es sind nicht nur Begriffe aus dem linken Diskurs, sondern man muss hier hinzufügen, diese Autoren halten alles für links, was jenseits einer bürgerlich-schwarz-blauen Koalition wäre. Das heißt also alles, was über Dobrindt, Weidel, Spahn hinausweist, nach links geht, ist links. Das heißt, wenn zum Beispiel die Rede ist von demokratischer Mitte, dann haben sie dafür auch in Lämmer demokratische Mitte. Ein Linker, und da muss man auch nicht mal Marxist für sein, findet diesen Begriff demokratische Mitte sehr verdächtig. Und würde sagen, ja genau das sollte man nicht machen. Und wer das auch anfängt und so redet, wie er zum Teil stattfindet dann in einem Podcast von Heidi Reich in Neck mit Ricarda Lang und so, da bin ich dann als Linker der, der sofort sagt, hör bitte auf mit diesem Kram. Das heißt, was hier alles als links dargestellt wird, wenn zum Beispiel von unserer Demokratie die Rede ist, dann ist das etwas, was man von links eher kritisieren würde, weil man sagt, naja, also unsere weiß ich gar nicht, und über was darf ich eigentlich in unserer Demokratie nicht abstimmen, zum Beispiel über die Produktionsverhältnisse. Das heißt also, dass es eine linke Demokratiekritik gibt, also eine Kritik an der bürgerlich-parlamentarischen Demokratie. Das wird hier überhaupt nicht erwähnt, weil man will alles als links darstellen, was nicht blau-schwarz ist. Was ich aber jetzt dem Buch zugute halten will, ist, dass es ja erst einmal sich in eine Tradition stellt. Nämlich, dass man sagt, es gibt also eine Hegemonie und wir müssen jetzt mal schauen, wie ist die denn geartet. Auch wenn das Ganze in dem Titel Links, Deutsch, Deutsch, Links ja eher etwas hat von dem Bestseller von Mario Bart. Manche werden sich erinnern, Frau, Deutsch, Deutsch, Frau. Ja, damals ein unglaublicher Erfolg. Ist das ja hier doch eine andere Tradition. Und zwar gab es ja nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg gleich von Sternberger, Dolph Sternberger, von Storz und Süßkind ein Buch, das hieß Aus dem Wörterbuch des Unmenschen. Das war ein Buch, das in auch so kurzen Artikeln, allerdings theoretisch brillanter und auch besser geschrieben, sich mit Naziwörtern auseinandersetzte. Interessanterweise aber nicht mit den Wörtern, die uns als erstes einfallen würden aus der NS-Zeit, auch vielleicht mit verbotenen Parolen oder so etwas, sondern mit folgenden Begriffen, ich habe das nochmal nachgeschaut, Betreuung, Einsatz, tragbar, durchführen. Und daran aufhängend beschäftigen sie sich dann mit der Ideologie der Nazis und wie die die Sprache verformt hat. Es gibt interessanterweise ein Lämmer in diesem alten Buch von Sternberger und anderen und in hier Links, Deutsch, Links, nämlich Kulturschaffende. Und da geht es in dem Buch von damals darum, dass man sagt, dass dieses zusammengesetzte Wort eigentlich folgendes sei. Und zwar von jener hybridischen Sorte, wie sie dann entsteht, wenn Zucht und Ordnung aufgehoben sind und im Interesse einer schrankenlosen Fruchtbarkeit, alles mit allem zusammengesetzt werden darf. Man stelle sich es ruhig im Bilder einer Oprigkeit, simulierten, geschlechtlichen Vermischung eines Lebensbornes vor. In der Sprachwissenschaft, die mit dem Vokabular des Unmenschen nicht zu Recht Schritt hält, bedeuten hybridische Wörter freilich etwas harmloseres. Kreuzungen aus zwei verschiedenen Sprachen wie Bürokrat oder Automobil. Das Interessante ist nun, wie dieses Wort Kulturschaffende von den Nazis gebraucht wird. Nämlich den modernen Unmenschen dürfen wir zwischen dem Barbaren und dem Ungeheuer platzieren. Denn über das bloß ungeschlachte und Fremde des Barbaren ist er in Richtung aufs Ungeheuerliche weit hinaus gelangt. Vermöge seiner übersteigerten Gebräuche, vom Nationalismus bis zum mechanischen Kulturvollzug. Denn ungleich dem naiven Barbaren legt er nicht nur die Merkmale und Amouletts der Kultur äußerlich an, sondern er übt Kultur aus. Er macht in Kultur, er hält sie mit immer größerer Selbstverständlichkeit für einen Gegenstand, eine Sparte innerhalb der Lebensorganisation, mit dem und dem Etat auszustatten, der und der Betreuung unterwerfen. Und dann geht das immer weiter. Ich will das jetzt nicht ausführen, wie sie denn weiter vorgehen. Was wir aber hier sehen können, ist, dass der Zugang ein vöjetonistischer ist, mit ein bisschen Sprachwissenschaft. Dass man also versucht, jetzt daraus abzuleiten, was eigentlich das Kulturverständnis der Nationalsozialisten war, um damit auch zu sagen, hütet euch vor diesen Begriffen. Auch heute haben wir diesen Begriff Kulturschaffender, den wir aber interessanterweise nicht mehr so sehr mit den Nazis verbinden. Es gibt nur wenige Journalisten, die immer mal wieder darauf hinweisen, Leute verwendet nicht immer diesen Begriff. Hier in diesem Buch jetzt nachgelesen, was die Kulturschaffenden meinen, will ich nur sagen.
Schritt für Schritt.
Deuten die das ja einfach so? Ja, alle Kulturschaffenden sind die, die Verrückten, die irgendwas Pro-Palästinensisches wollen.
Genau. Von daher, wir können uns jetzt ewig aufladen mit der Frage, was leistet typischerweise ein Wörterbuch und welche guten Beispiele gibt es? Und da gibt es ja einige. Ich kenne es nicht, aber die Nuzizen eines Phädologen, Viktor Klemperer, LTI, Ja. 1947 erschienen, zu dem man, wenn man Wikipedia und so weiter folgt, ich habe mir Beispiele durchgelesen, würde sagen, also das trifft auf jeden Fall zu, Begriffe werden erörtert. Er nimmt sich also die Begriffe, mit denen die Nazis wirklich Staat organisiert haben und deutet sie, ich will nicht sagen spekulativ, aber suchend, erörternd, für sich erklärend.
Ja, er erörtert die Nazi-Sprache, geht da sprachwissenschaftlich vor, ja.
Publiziert eben auch für uns. Also jeder Begriff kriegt einen konkreten Fundort. Eine Rede, Zeitungsartikel, Plakate, das fehlt hier komplett. Woher diese Begriffe kommen, erfahren wir nicht. Es hängt alles so ein bisschen in der Luft. Zweitens, es gibt keine Historisierung. Wann taucht ein Wort auf? Wer prägt es? Wie wandert es? Diffusion in die Gesellschaft. Genau hier verweigert sich ja sogar das Buch. Es wird ja genau nicht das erklären. Wir haben keine Selbstreflektion, sondern wir haben so eine selbstverklärende Sprachsammlung von Worten bei denen. Und da muss man halt jetzt, finde ich, so ein bisschen rein spekulieren. Wir haben hier audio-synchratische Sprache von Leuten, die unter sich sind, die eigentlich keinen Kontakt zur Gesellschaft haben, sondern alles, was sie von der Gesellschaft sehen, in ihrer eigenen Sprache reformulieren und gar nicht mehr sich irritieren lassen und erst recht nicht neugierig auf Gesellschaft sind. Sondern wir haben genau diesen Einiegelungsprozess. Und nun haben wir ja noch ein paar Publizisten, die jenseits von dieser völlig abgeschlossenen Newsbubble sind. Ich will nur sagen Jan Fleischhauer und Ulf Poschert. Die kommen beide in diesem Buch nicht vor. Und das finde ich erstaunlich, denn ich will jetzt mal folgendes Argument machen. Wir haben einen Medienbetrieb, über den sich die lustig machen. Die bauen ihren eigenen Medienbetrieb. Julian Reichelt ist nicht freiwillig von Springer gegangen, aber er ist sozusagen von dem einen Milliardär zum nächsten Milliardär gewandert. Und man kann jetzt über Matthias Döfner schon viel Negatives sagen. Aber der neue Milliardär, der den er gefunden hat, der macht ja nur noch diese Bubble. Matthias Döfner betreibt wenigstens noch ein paar Apps oder so in seiner Firma. Also ein bisschen in der Gesellschaft ist Springer noch. Das neue ja gar nicht. Und Jan Fleishauer und Ulf Poschert, die jetzt selbst für diese Bubble sich nicht eignen, aber schon eigentlich komplett disqualifiziert sind, sind ja erbärmliche Gestalten und zwar beide auf ihre eigene Weise. Sie finden noch so im normalen Mainstream statt. Aber bei Jan Fleishauer ist schon klar, der muss seine eigene Figur mittlerweile spielen, damit das CDF sagt, ja wir brauchen mal so einen Konservativen, aber wir finden nur noch einen, der sich selber nicht mehr so ernst nimmt, der eigentlich super wütend ist, aber der verpackt das immer so in Humor. Über Humor ist ein bisschen Anschlussfähig. Wir geben ihm mal einen Sendeplatz kurz vor Mitternacht.
Ja, weil sie sich nicht trauen, Reichelt den Platz zu geben.
Ja, so wenn Fleishauer diesen Korridor verlassen würde, könnte er schon nicht mehr bei Maischberger mit am Kommentartisch sitzen. Und Ulf Poschardt ist ja mittlerweile, also er spielt ja nur noch für Matthias Döpfner. Wir sind ja alle nur noch Zuschauer von Ulf Poschards Spiel für das Ein-Mann-Publikum Matthias Döpfner. So, das ist schon dramatisch und traurig. Dieses Buch steigert das alles. Also hier haben sich sehr wütende und auch in so einer gewissen kulturellen Depression befindliche Leute einfach zusammengerottet und haben halt mit sich und den Wörtern und den Texten Spaß. Also die schreiben sich das so hin und her. Ja voll toll, machen wir hier noch die Pointe rein, wie auch immer. Man kann sich ja den redaktionellen Text so ungefähr Ablauf vorstellen. Aber wenn man hier einsteigt inhaltlich, ich meine, die Pauline Voss schreibt hier Transfrau. Die. Dann wird in der Unterzeile aber substantiv maskulin geschrieben. Und die einzige Erklärung zu diesem Begriff ist Mann, Punkt.
Ja, womit sie sagen wollen, es gibt keine Transfrauen.
Das ist doch lächerlich. Also klar kann man jetzt hier so ein...
Das ist aber eine Sache, worauf sich alle einigen können, ist, dass sie Trans-Leute hassen. Also das ist ja, was sie sehr unverblümt hier artikulieren, indem sie dann zum Beispiel ihnen das auch absprechen, Trans zu sein. Worauf sie sich auch natürlich einigen können, ist, dass sie gegen Migration sind. Aber das müssen sie ein bisschen besser verpacken.
Ah, also wir gehen es mal durch.
Ja, ich will was ich nur sagen will. Man ist immer noch so auf diesem Diskurs, dass man sagen kann, wenn man heute rassistisch argumentiert, dann unterscheidet sich das ja von Rassisten zum Beispiel aus der Zeit des Nationalsozialismus dadurch, dass man nicht eine Rassenlehre direkt als Grundlage bringen kann und darauf argumentiert man. Dann bekommt man ja ein Problem. Das heißt, der Umweg zum Rassismus geht immer über die sind nicht qualifiziert als Arbeitskräfte, die stechen mit Messern herum, die machen dies und das. Das heißt, man muss heute, um den rassistischen Diskurs zu beflügeln, sozusagen tun, als sei man kein Rassist. Und das ist ganz interessant, während sie das zum Beispiel bei Transpersonen nicht tun, da gehen sie nochmal anders damit um. Was ich nur sagen will, ist, dass wir ja tatsächlich gewisse Begriffe da wiederfinden, die ich auch furchtbar finde. Also die ich sage, wenn die Leute ständig von demokratischer Mitte oder unserer Demokratie reden, wird mir auch übel. Wenn ich den Satz höre, wir brauchen neue Narrative, dann will ich eigentlich auch sofort den Raum verlassen. Wenn irgendjemand nochmal ankommt mit Hass und Hetze, dann muss ich da ironisch mich drüber heben. Und da ist vielleicht ein Defizit, um das nur zu benennen, auf einer linken Seite da, dass man sich zu wenig eigentlich über diese Art des Sprechens lustig macht. Und das ist nämlich etwas, was, glaube ich, so eine Kerbe ist, wo die hier einschlagen können. Was interessant ist, ist, dass sie ja erst einmal ganz den Schritt...
Na warte, lass mich mal Schritt für Schritt, weil das ist... Du bist jetzt wieder abgebogen auf, da schreiben welche, ich habe die Blase beschrieben, ein geschlossenes Milieu, autosynchrotischer Sprache, die sich über Sprache lustig machen. Jetzt sagst du, da gibt es Worte drin, da schlucke ich auch, muss man jetzt, hat ja Stefan in seinem Kommentar geschrieben, auch angemerkt, muss man wirklich den Flüchtlingen Flüchtender nennen. Und da denke ich mir, man steckt selber in einer Blabbel drin, wenn man auf dieses Buch reagiert, in dem man sagt, ja, was progressive weibliche Regierungskreise in ihrem Podcast in Berlin publizieren, ist ja auch wichtig. Da möchte ich ganz klar sagen, ist es nicht. Ist es nicht. Ich weiß, es gibt Leute, also du sagst das zu Recht, ich weiß, es gibt Leute, denen ist ganz wichtig, hier nochmal ein Hass und Hetze Argument zu machen und hier nochmal den Appell auf demokratische Einheit, was auch immer. Wir bekämpfen jetzt hier die Demokratie. Ich weiß, dass es das in Berlin gibt.
Und über die muss man sich auch lustig machen.
Ja, über die kann man sich sehr gerne lustig machen, aber die finden halt in unserer Auseinandersetzung mit diesem Buch, würde ich sagen, jetzt mal keine Rolle, denn das Gegenbeispiel...
Ich hätte so ein Buch eigentlich hätte man das in Intelligent machen sollen von Links.
Ja, man kann alles möglich machen. Mit diesen ganzen Begriffen. Ich möchte anmerken...
Ich hätte eigentlich gerne ein Wörterbuch, Demokratie, Deutsch, Deutsch Demokratie oder so.
Ja, also ich will es mal so markieren. Dieses Buch unter der Kritik, die du jetzt gemacht hast, findet in Berlin ein Publikum, das sich ganz maßlos darüber aufregt und Podcasts macht und sagt, so geht es ja gar nicht. Ich will aber anmerken, dieser Podcast hier wird im Bahnhofsviertel Frankfurt am Main aufgenommen und die Nachbarstadt Offenbach hat die meisten Ausländer von ganz Deutschland und die AfD hat bei der Kommunalwahl 5% oder so errungen. So, wenn wir mit dem Buch nach Offenbach fahren, machen sich alle darüber lustig, fragen sich, was ist denn das, blättern kurz durch, schmeißen es weg. Das ist ein richtiger Umgang damit. Wir dürfen jetzt nicht immer nur alles, weil Heidi Reicheneck einen Podcast macht.
Nein, nein, nein, nein. Sondern wir sehen das mal wahr. Ich wollte das nur einführen. Aber den Schritt, der hier ja gemacht wird, dass sie denen gehen, das ist ja verräterisch. Denn es ist ja so, ich hatte es schon vorgelesen.
Wollen wir vorher Beispiele durchgehen? Ich habe Beispiele zusammengesammelt, bevor wir so viele Urteile fällen. Man weiß ja gar nicht, worüber wir reden.
Wir müssen noch den ersten Satz besprechen. Nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache. Und die politisch mediale Sprache in Deutschland ist Links. Nehmen wir mal das erste. Nichts ist mächtiger als Sprache. Das ist ja interessant, dass hier von rechts etwas aufgegriffen wird, was die ganze Zeit von Links so stark gemacht wurde, nämlich aus den Universitäten heraus. Seit dem Linguistik Turn der 60er Jahre hat man sich ja sehr darauf konzentriert, die Sprache zu verändern. Man hat sich sehr damit abgefunden, dass es die materiellen Bedingungen gibt und da ist wenig zu ändern. Das heißt, weniger Arbeitskampf. Kein auf die Barrikaden, sondern wir verändern die Sprache. Denn Sprechen ist Handeln und wenn wir das Sprechen verändert haben, dann haben wir damit auch die Welt verändert. Interessanterweise ist diese, sagen wir, linksliberale Prämisse, die ich auch von links kritisieren würde, hier eine, die von rechts mitgegangen wird. Nämlich von Julian Reichelt. Und da zeigt sich also schon, dass die gerne diesen ewigen Kampf um die Sprache ja wollen. Sie wollen nichts anderes als das, denn sie tun genau das, was ich jetzt auch linksliberalen vorgeworfen habe, die nur das Sprechen ändern wollen. Sie wollen irgendwelche anderen Begriffe und wollen auch mal wieder rassistisch sein dürfen und wollen nicht sich da gemassregelt fühlen durch irgendwelche Sprache, die eingefordert wird. Aber woran sie genau nichts ändern wollen, das ist die materielle Grundlage. Denn in diesem gesamten Buch wird nicht ein einziges Mal über die soziale Frage in dem Sinne gesprochen, dass man vielleicht über eine Umverteilung nachdenkt. Man spricht nicht über die wirtschaftlichen Schwierigkeiten, die sich ergeben haben aus verschiedenen globalen Entwicklungen. Man spricht nicht über das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit, sondern wirft nur an einer Stelle sogar mal den Linken vor. Wir würden gar nicht mehr über das Verhältnis von Kapital und Arbeit reden, um es dann selbst nicht zu tun. Stattdessen lassen Sie nochmal Wolfgang Kubicki aufschreiben, warum die Vermögenssteuer wirklich das Allerschlimmste wäre, wenn sie eingeführt würde.
Also was mich an dem Buch interessiert ist nicht, wo es sich selbst als Beitrag in einem Diskurs positioniert. Also bitte seh mir nach, wenn wir jetzt die Liste der Ich finde Worte interessant da drin durchgehen. Ich weiß, dass es eine linke Partei gibt, die irgendwo in Deutschland irgendwas publiziert und auch eine Meinung hat und so. Aber mich interessiert hier nicht, das sind offensichtlich Rechte, also das Verhältnis von rechts und links. Mich interessiert jetzt das Verhältnis von rechts und Realität. Ja, das wird man da kaum wieder finden. So, und da gehen wir jetzt mal die Worte durch. Also, die Transfrau ist kein Mann. Also das ist einfach empirisch widerlegte Biologie, widerspricht dem komplett. Auch die ganze Binaritätsunterstellung, die da drinsteckt, Frau, Mann und so, ist einfach so nicht gegeben. Das kann man sich anders wünschen und dann viele Argumentationen dazu machen. Alle lager schlagen da über die Stränge, aber die Realität hält ihm einfach nicht stand. Der Faktenchecker. Im Auftrag regierungsnahe Medien, Tätiger, Journalist, der stets nachzuweisen hat, dass die Kritiker, dass die Kritiker etwas falsches behaupten und die Regierung immer recht hat. So, also wenn wir jetzt Friedrich Merz einsortieren mit der Faktenchecker, gibt Friedrich Merz immer recht und die Faktenchecker sind aber immer Linke, die das einfordern, listen to the signs, wie auch immer. Also es passt auch einfach nicht zusammen. Wir werden gerade nicht von Gregor Gysi regiert. Die Morddrohung. Im Plural-Kampfinstrument der politischen Linken, um sich nach deftigen Reaktionen auf ihre Provokationen als Opfer gerieren zu können, gewissermaßen das Arschgewall der Hass-Kamarilla. Also ich habe auch viele Rechte im Ohr, die die ganze Zeit mit, ich kriege eine Morddrohung hier, ich werde angefeindet, bla bla. Es hält auch wirklich keine, also hier darf man einfach gar nicht drüber nachdenken. Nur dann kann man das überhaupt aufschreiben. Und es läuft natürlich alles auf eine Megapointe zum Thema, Friedrich schreibt über Framing hinaus, aber das Auto.
Ja, lass uns doch da gleich weitermachen. Wir diskutieren also jetzt ausführlich über dieses Buch und ich will es nochmal deutlich machen, für mich ist es schon so eine Art Gründungsdokument einer möglichen schwarz-blauen Koalition.
Aber erst gehen wir es inhaltlich durch.
Ja, ja, okay, aber ich will das schon sagen, dass man das so lesen muss. Denn nur weil es abgrundtief dumm ist, heißt es nicht, dass es nicht wirksam sein kann.